so it sounds like it's up for state law
in in most of these cases you embarked
on this journey 30 years ago thinking
hey we should run presidential elections
via ranked Choice voting uh what are the
steps we would need to take because uh
I've been saying for a while we could be
staring at a trump Biden rematch and a
lot of Americans would look up saying
like hey like what are my other choices
the the major counter argument right now
is like oh if anyone else runs it's
gonna spoil it for one party the other
Ralph Nader effect et cetera Etc
um so what do we need to do to actually
make it so Americans could have multiple
choices in a presidential election well
so we talked about the presidential
primaries for the general election
currently that's all done state by state
right so Maine now uses ranked us voting
for president so in Maine
in 2020 you know people ranked
candidates and there was like a green
Party candidate there was a Libertarian
candidate and uh Joe Biden uh actually
got more than half the votes so those
the ballot didn't need to kind of kick
into the second choices but those people
could vote for the green and libertarian
and and not worry about the
quote-unquote spoiler effect so that's
something that each state can do on its
own just using ranked us voting within
the state
there is
um fun ideas in fact I wrote a long
article for the the Harvard Law Policy
Journal about how you could combine
State action on rankers voting with
State action toward the national popular
vote interstate compact plan that is
established as a way to effectively have
States unite to create a national
popular vote for president and they they
actually could could build
um Rangers voting on top of that um and
there's sort of laid that out but that's
that's the way that you effectively
could actually have a state driven
process that that allows states to to be
part of a national public but for
president if we ever want a a truly
United
States of America election
um we would need a constitutional
amendment
um to kind of lock in that will have a
national popular vote and that would be
the time to have a conversation
about how to have the method of election
for President as we change the
Constitution you you can do it with the
national popular vote plan sort of state
by state or you could sort of do it do
do it do a kind of this you know
constitutional change which is I don't
think we're very close to doing and and
but that is that's where you
theoretically could do it one thing
that's interesting when you look at all
the presidential elections around the
world and where a lot of countries have
Prime Ministers Who come out of the
legislature but there are a number of
states our countries rather that that
vote directly for president pretty much
all of them do require a majority
and most of them do a runoff election
but like say Ireland has has ranked for
his voting for president and uh but but
that idea of upholding majority rule
that you should get at least half the
votes to become you know the chief
executive is a general principle that's
out there and I think that that
conversation is is an important one for
us to have and partly why we should have
rankers voting state by state for
Governors as well right it's like we
should make sure that the folks who are
you know in that important position of
power uh have done the work necessary to
earn majority support yeah who the heck
wants someone who didn't get 50 of the
vote you know what I mean like and I
mean uh that's one of the reasons why
Maine adopted it is that you had uh
Governor LePage win without 50 of the
vote they looked around and said well
that's not cool
they had like three consecutive
governors
one Democrat one Republican and one
independent so conveniently like each
side got got it got a got a chance to
win with less than 40 percent right so
now weighing like 38 36 or whatever and
um at least they're one of those pretty
definitively would not have won in a
head-to-head contest and uh that created
a conversation so it wasn't surprising
that Maine was the first state to pass
it so it sounds like for the
presidential you have this uh
Constitutional Amendment approach uh for
a national election
um or just you get a bunch of States on
board so it's already in effect uh in
Maine
um and so if you had enough States
adopted and certainly I'm I'm very very
excited about the state-by-state
approach all right Rob so here's an idea
where we do it nationwide check it out
the 2020 presidential election gets
decided by maybe 70 000 votes in four
states uh and the 2024 race will
probably be similar so the four swing
States uh that everyone knows are going
to be very very close are Nevada Arizona
Georgia and Wisconsin those things are
probably going to be within a percent
and then if you were to expand it a
little bit to two percent you end up
including Pennsylvania and Michigan
right uh so very many by the way no no
it shows how messed up our system is
like 44 States uh you're baked Six
States you know maybe might swing One
Direction or another so they have all
the power and the political ads they can
look forward to that but let's imagine
that you got a coalition of oh let's say
500 000 Independents or swing voters in
those Six States uh to say we are going
to back whichever
presidential candidate comes out for
non-partisan primaries and ranked Choice
voting and maybe let's throw it in there
the fair representation act which you
and I can talk about
you could get this fulcrum because our
country's so polarized and our system is
so dumb
honestly you could make it a winning
issue in the 2024 presidential race
between the two major parties call it
five and six which stands for five
percent in six swing States what do you
think I think that is a potent concept
you just have to find if you can find
those if you if you can find the voters
you can find five percent probably even
three percent but hey five percent is
all the better
who
agreed to prioritize that and it's it's
really challenging for a lot of people
because they can say well I really love
these issues but I care about
something else that's associated with
that party you know
their views on abortion rights or
climate change or you know
economic issues of a certain kind right
like like you have to essentially say
I'm going to make for this election make
those secondary I am going to vote based
on these priorities because if we can
make this change it'll make a change in
our politics that'll allow me to be able
to do Forever After much more of what I
want about all the other things that I
care about so so if you can persuade
people to do that it would be very
powerful right it would be it would be a
foolish candidate
who essentially said no as particularly
I think those issues are good issues
like obviously I'm I'm biased but but I
but I think those issues are ones that
voters would appreciate a candidate
being for right it it is a kind of a
voter's first agenda right which is like
that candidate is standing up for voters
doing the right thing
um and these five percent of people are
are now going to vote for them which you
know if if you do the math if they're
not all from one side right if they're
sort of like include some people who
might vote Republican and some people
who might let's say half and half even
ideally that would be the powerful thing
right if you truly have a certain set of
Swing people that would mean that
whoever makes that position if only one
of them does is getting this boost which
given the way our politics is that's a
huge boost yeah very powerful so Asian
Americans are 9.1 percent of the uh
electorate in Nevada 4.4 percent in
Georgia so those are two states three
percent in the other states uh and they
they tend to be a very uh pragmatic
group uh so not ideological as well
um so I I think you could make this
happen
um and I I may be spending a significant
amount of time and energy making this
happen
five and six yeah no five and six that's
it's a that that that's five and six and
twenty four yeah that that that yeah the
math will have we'll have to work that
out you it could be four and six and 24
and then it would all like be like a
sort of like a product Oh my gosh you're
right because the fact is you're right
that five percent uh isn't even
necessary I mean these versions four
percent if it's evenly divided that does
it like like if you get two percent
Republican leaning two percent
Democratic leaning
that that's enough
[Music]